what's up reject nation we're gonna do a
reaction today to his ease comedy recap
doves of Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
my parents caught me yesterday how'd you
do him what was under the covers with a
flashlight looking at a couple of
magazines
yeah can we talk about this later no I
have to tell the reject nation about
these magazines and so do you why cuz
today's video is sponsored by a giant
panda king late last year we started
getting to know the people behind giant
panda king I don't think they'll
appreciate your story about masturbate
oh they will because they're amazing
people who are taking creativity and
fandom to a whole other level with all
their layers of star wars sexiness yeah
I touch myself too internationally gpk
is best known for the Empire strips back
there touring burlesque cabaret set in
the Star Wars universe should we show
them our magazines that are now super
stinky we should get more copies cuz
that is super gross looking rhotic we
actually read both of these magazines
cover to cover best way to describe them
is thinking them like a old seventies
playboy mag in the Star Wars universe
yeah the detail in them is nuts oh I
busted a nut wait wait Greg YouTube
censorship it doesn't matter anymore
after we show them what's in this
magazine
they've got pinup centerfolds erotic
comics jokes party tips and a whole lot
of galactic babes no baby there Jones
I'm leaving she has ex Neider what I
want to tell them about this Gotham book
you have terrible segues dude if you go
to giant panty Kings website you'll see
this is just the tip of the gpk iceberg
for example something completely
different than their wookie Radhika mags
is this Gotham 1919 to 1939 buck that's
a good segue see I read this book in the
matter of two days it takes the
characters and mythology of Batman and
reimagine them as part of Depression era
American history so head on over to
their website today and thank you once
again giant panda king for partnering up
with us in sponsoring this video oh yeah
looking forward to those free tickets to
their burlesque show they didn't agree
to that oh they will
they will take guys this episode is
brought to you by Nord VPN right now get
70% off more VPN only 349 a month plus
you get an additional month free
check out the leading edge with more
details yeah these are so funny
Hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you gotta find one of these things it's
called a holic I mean away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
would you stand all for boning on top of
that row oh crap he's coming with her
boyfriend again first time yeah it's
right not to be captured
[Music]
who did
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we thought you were stormtroopers
no way I used to be a stormtrooper
do you take there's like us like
millions we could maybe save the Empire
I mean the first order I mean the final
order now let's do them all whoa we
almost gave your character an arc there
talked about that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah just like every single time
before we don't have enough people
shorten we wait till Lando gets back
with everyone and attack do you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh do you even have a plan give
me our life force
hard as you can over 40 years ago it
would help remind you woman I'm ray-ray
[Music]
this is where you lived yeah Wow I
really liked our first
hahaha you guys I'm ray-ray Skye
[Music]
I've really lucked out what just
happened when we were doing this
reaction remind me of that back scratch
bit when he was doing I think it was the
infinity war reaction what his dog's
first party been so it's a real life
moment and that's part of what you come
here for yeah sometimes random stuff
happens when you're watching the full
video on the internet well if we weren't
filming and we were just watching this
on our own I probably would have paused
the video and I would have cleaned this
up everything gets ruined whatever
happens our internet modem box fell over
which knocked over our leveler which we
have for the camera which then fell onto
the desk which knocked over John's
coffee which spilled on a bunch of
papers that's a great chain reaction
we're both for sensitive and we didn't
even know is like that hasn't followed
over once and just happens to occur Moe
get ready it's gonna happen more times
yeah I love the final line of like I got
lucky with Luke and Leia standing there
because that's so true Leia gets to go
to Alderaan and gets to be the daughter
of Bail Organa like the senator because
she gets this privileged life and you're
on Tatooine with Owen and Beru yeah
you're stuck here from here on out you
like two sides of a coin right it really
is it really is there are some great
points I didn't even bother to think
about here that were brought over here
though I know this video is not about
the criticism of the points which is
what they're always sneakily doing right
no yeah what that's what they do with
their comedy dubs they're making fun of
it they're throwing in their jokes the
personalities the voice-over work which
is always a lot of fun they're doing
like the OneNote attitude of EJ's
characters like oh the rent right yeah
this is a great example of that I just
set for there at the end yeah which i
think is my favorite of all of the hizzy
characters love that voice especially
look at my fingers
like the most evil fingers you've ever
seen listen pretty hard to do the
Emperor bits here because there's always
the shadow lightning effects so they
have to always really because I imagine
you can slap on the mouth and the
editing but then for the Emperor you
have to keep calculating it and dealing
with the shadow effects that are
happening that way the mouth is an
overlap in the shadow that's what I
adore is when you have this silly
looking mouth that they then have to
apply a realistic lighting effect to
make it blend in with the rest of the
scene and that's I mean that's a pretty
great just your mark of what makes these
so amusing to me is like you saying they
do raise good points but they're hidden
in this race raised ready for a more
race
sorry right dark brave own right like
bait ready okay I mean that's a good
play right there because for all
intensive purposes it really is just
yeah oh it's so funny too with the whole
like I want to be in a woman no thing I
didn't even think about that I didn't
think about that e or the things
Kathleen Kennedy won't Star Wars right
Oh in Star Wars nobody knew that the
Emperor was secretly trans all along
other subjects but I didn't even think
about it with like Finn and we could
have set up a whole character art for
you and the stormtroopers me actually
just nah Batman I'm Batman or just cold
like fat man beyond now I was called yet
Kevin Smith when he was doing one of his
live podcast he was saying that a friend
brought up to him how that would have
been a very effective character arc for
Finn and that really bummed him out and
having been at his mind
yeah oh that would have been the perfect
arc for Finn his story of fn-2187
becomes a person who helped leave the
new resistance a stormtrooper who
defected and inspired a whole bunch of
other stormtroopers too but then they
don't do anything with it let's just
kill them all they're people too
yeah actually there's just these two
people and the rest of them ask her
anyway I thought this video was really
well edited I think that was my favorite
comedic aspect especially like with the
way the story in the actual movie Mirai
the amount of stuff they have to cram in
yeah a lot of things they're like here's
a decision and now we're editing right
to next scene
oh yeah especially though random cuts of
Rage is running and I gotta get away
okay bye yeah and they even changed up
the narrative a bit it didn't hit me
until we're ray confronts the Emperor
everybody's like I'm your grandpappy or
something but they cut out the whole
thing with ray learning she is really
the oh you're a daughter of Palpatine
that whole scene between kylo and ray
they cut that whole thing out it chose
to be and they just put it here and it
didn't hit me till there so they
slightly condensed the storytelling here
yeah this is really funny man I love
that they give a nickname to kylo Ren
here Benjamin Chewbacca solo that would
have to be his middle name
yeah this is kind of honor yeah humble
dude yeah I love that joke with Maz
Kanata of this will remind you of all
the friends that are all dead now and
the Knights of Ren just posing ever more
badass Lee to do yeah you know I wish
kylo Ren did show up at the end with all
the ghosts late with Luke and Leia and
he was still in his dark loading his SIF
clothing well you know I mean that's all
of his wardrobe it's just black stuff
you know even if he's not in the full
garb you know he still looks like a city
monk or something
the bitter jabs about nostalgia for
box-office boost with Lando and Luke and
I love how every time Chewie like that
thing to about rays you know power being
consequential and having downsides like
oh we have this opportunity to make a
big statement not Juiz find their
reoccurring bit that they used cousin
that in the trailer with a fly down they
fly down like they didn't do that joke
here but instead they sprinkled they did
a couple of times and would like she
uses life force now she can force heal
now from life healing now yeah they were
sealing for a really nice rule of threes
joke I didn't see coming and I thought
they got some nice mileage
everyone's favorite trailers are like
roads saying I want to come no you stop
yeah like really solid jokes in here
this is some really funny stuff one of
their best I think yeah I took a line
between silliness but astute yeah
alright guys well if you haven't checked
out the video in its original format
make sure to go to the link in
description box where the link is there
you know intron sects subscriber the
real rejects please click that
notification fell again notify would
never forgot a youtube video up thanks
again to giant panicking for sponsoring
this video make sure to go out to their
website today see you guys soon more
videos to come this week